[Musique]
en juillet prochain plusieurs artistes
comme Bigflo et Oli damso soprano ou
encore Louise Attaque et Indochine
doivent se produire au festival Les
Déferlantes
[Musique]
dans les deux groupes d'Europe français
risquent bien de boycotter l'événement
initialement prévu à céréales le
festival se déroulera finalement à
Perpignan une ville dirigée par le maire
rassemblement national Louis à Lyon nous
demandons à la direction des déferlantes
de déplacer ce festival dans un autre
lieu faute de quoi nous annulerons notre
venue et ce matin quelques jours après
cette annonce du groupe Indochine c'est
au tour de Louise Attaque d'écrire ce
communiqué en l'état actuel des choses
nous nous souhaitons pas participer à
cet événement des menaces de boycott qui
font bondir le président du
Rassemblement national Jordan Bardella
quand on est artiste on fait pas de la
politique on ne trie pas les gens qui
viennent à ces concerts en fonction de
leur opinion politique de son côté le
festival regrette que la politique
vienne s'immiscer dans la musique
annulation d'un festival à Perpignan
ville RN comprenez-vous le boycott des
artistes
[Musique]
de la politique partout en fait déjà ils
font passer les artistes pour qu'il
reste pour des gens politisés puisque
quelque part de fait en restant ça veut
dire qu'ils soutiennent le RN alors que
pas du tout et en fait encore une fois
qui sont-ils pour se permettre ça c'est
parce que c'est des artistes privilégiés
mais est-ce que vous voyez un autre
métier faire ça est-ce que vous voyez un
restaurateur refusé de servir des
clients parce qu'il m'intéresse ça
n'existe pas ça n'a aucun sens
encore une fois pour faire le lien avec
le débat d'avant face à des gens qui ne
prennent que ce qu'il y a de bon dans
leur statut donc quand c'est pour
prendre l'oseille attentivement des
albums etc il y a pas de problème par
contre là une fois qu'ils sont blindés
là c'est toi tu rentres toi tu rentres
pas c'est dangereux c'est honteux et
c'est presque du sectarisme et
franchement c'est dégueulasse de faire
ça pour tout leur public Gilles Verdez
alors je suis d'accord moi je suis en
colère quand même contre le maire
Monsieur aleo bah tu vas pouvoir lui
dire il va il a l'air dans un bateau tu
vas lui dire parce qu'il va arriver dans
un instant en fait non mais calme-toi
donc après puis tu vas lui dire après
bien sûr mais c'est mieux de fois j'aime
bien que tu étais le reste je ne suis
pas d'accord avec les artistes toi tu
étais tu as le cul entre deux chaises
pas du tout mais je vais lui dire ce que
j'ai à lui dire si vous me le permettez
je me suis dit oui
là je vais parler d'autre chose bon bah
tu parleras après moi moi je dis
résolument non je dis il faut absolument
aller dans n'importe quel endroit et
surtout à cet endroit là faut envoyer de
la musique et de l'amour si un endroit
où il faut aller exercer son art oui
pourquoi condamner les gens dans la
salle les gens sont pas des gens du
et comme je dis à chaque fois nous on
n'est pas comme les autres les donneurs
de leçons qui vous disent faut voter
pour un tel faut pas voter pour un tel
il faut chacun voit midi à sa porte et
chacun à la vie qu'il a donc nous on est
des privilégiés donc forcément et je
vous le dis quand je le dis à chaque
fois il y a plein de gens ils ont voté à
gauche ils étaient encore dans la merde
à droite aussi milieu pareil donc un
moment ils disent qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de toute façon on est dans la merde on
est dans la merde Kelly ça y aura
Valérie Valérie t'inquiète pas tu vas
avoir une grosse plage
selon moi il faut y aller il faut y
aller pour passer un message moi je
trouve que c'est important si tu as
quelque chose à dire sur scène fais-le
et là tout le monde t'entendra parce que
à faire un truc comme ça moi je trouve
pas que ça ouvre le débat au contraire
ça le ferme et ça mais si moi je trouve
que ça le ferme au final et et qui
s'appuie en fait ça punit les personnes
qui sont fan d'eux et qui n'ont pas
spécialement choisi de vivre dans cette
ville et qui sont peut-être pas d'accord
avec ceux qui dirigent la ville donc ça
punit des femmes et qu'est-ce qu'on leur
dit à ses fans là alors on leur crash
dessus on leur disant bah moi je viens
pas dans ta vie et c'est à dire que
chacun doit déménager de cette ville là
parce qu'elle est représentée par des
gens qui ne sont pas non mais
tu dis il faut y aller mais pour faire
passer un message mais un message de
quoi en quoi un artiste est plus
intelligent ou moins intelligent que
quelqu'un de normal donc il y a un
moment c'est juste une démocratie voilà
si tu es pas d'accord tu y vas pas sinon
il y a un moment tu vas dans une ville
voilà qui a choisi et même tu n'as pas
sur moi j'ai plus rien que ça tu n'as
pas sur scène à donner de message parce
que tu devrais la pression que les gens
qui sont là toi tu sais eux ils savent
pas qu'est-ce que tu sais de plus ce du
sel c'est faire de la musique pour le
reste c'est pas plus intelligent que les
autres donc donne pas de message et suis
juste la démocratie les gens ont voté
c'est bien une chose qui est belle en
France il y en a pas 10000 c'est qu'on a
une démocratie responsables en France
Raymond après Valérie tu auras ta plage
ça me fait le même effet Guillaume en
fait j'ai l'impression que tu vas
sanctionner d'abord les gens qui sont
pas Front national tu vas les
sanctionner il y aura pas Indochine et
toujours pareil ça me dit que Indochine
aujourd'hui peuvent se permettre de dire
je ne viens pas mais les autres années
ils ont été dans des villes front
nationales ça les a pas dérangés les
autres années aujourd'hui ils trient ça
il y a plein d'artistes une fois qu'ils
sont connus une fois qu'ils sont tout en
haut ils se permettent de dire moi je
vais pas c'est le Front National Front
national c'est pas mes idées mais moi si
j'étais un artiste j'irai avec Soprano
j'irai avec David Guetta j'irai avec
Bigflo et Oli parce qu'il y a des gens
dans cette ville
il y a des gens dans
Maigret avec tout le monde et compagnie
maintenant qu'aujourd'hui alors vous en
faites pour national vous le faites plus
rien puisque simplement plus rien moi je
dirais jamais rassemblement national je
dirais Front national tant que je serai
en vie je dirais Front national si vous
vous échangez de nom changer de personne
les mettent plus beau leur changer de
costume
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça voilà
c'est aujourd'hui la République en
marche s'appelle plus la République
c'est pas le même je trouve c'est comme
par hasard c'est Indochine c'est des
dictats de groupe bobo de gauche
parisien etc à ce point-là on détourne
on déplace le concert on va aller dans
une marée ça serait de la France
insoumise ça se fera Bigflo et Oli ah
moi je joue pas dans une mairie qui est
détenu par un maire la France insoumise
on a on rentre dans des délires
complètement délirant d'intellectuel de
gauche qui se la raconte parce qu'ils
ont un socle de de de de fan comme ça
mais c'est c'est à l'encontre du métier
d'artiste on doit jouer pour tout le
monde avant d'avoir
la vie de Valérie quand même apprendre
d'abord
si on pousse le bouchon encore plus loin
à ce moment il dans une mairie normale
mais avant il demande pour qui vous avez
voté dans une mairie normale il t'a voté
et Rennes aux dernières élections là tu
rentres pas donc on fait pousser le la
bêtise Front national de boycotter
Indochine toute personne qui a voté
Front national n'allait plus au concert
d'Indochine
voilà regarde ce qu'ils ont regardé la
sélection ce qui s'est passé
beaucoup de gens ils ont demandé à la
lune et ben tu dors du monde plus rien
Valérie les fans qui écoutent Indochine
tombent pas de l'armoire puisque déjà en
2017 non ils ont fait une chanson contre
le Front national contre le RN donc je
crois qu'ils étaient sur une armoire
là où je dis oui c'est parce que je
pense effectivement comme vous que c'est
à mon avis contre-productif mais malgré
tout un artiste fait ce qu'il veut bien
sûr on peut pas obligé un artiste à se
produire là où il a pas envie de se
produire et par ailleurs la jeunesse de
l'histoire c'est que ils ont été mis
devant le fait accompli ils devaient pas
se produire dans cette ville et au
dernier moment on leur a dit bah
finalement ce sera là et donc ils ont
dit bah non nous on décide que non donc
voilà il faut aussi remettre dans
l'histoire dans son contexte donc voilà
Spider-Man
profiter de cet événement pour faire son
ce ça pub autour d'eux voilà et moi et
moi je pense par ailleurs que par
contrairement à ce que dit Jordan
Bardella un artiste c'est aussi
politique Picasso quand il fait Guernica
c'est politique
le risque de se couper mais c'est le
choix et ils font ce choix en
connaissance de cause et
on est d'accord
vous acceptez de jouer ou que tu
regardes les dates où tout le monde est
d'accord pour jouer les endroits tourner
d'accord
si vous voulez pas le jouer ou quand tu
vas regarder un festival bah si c'est ça
c'est la carte
avec nous hein voilà il est là alors lui
a dit Oh maire de Perpignan
bonsoir Louis oui vous allez oui oui
bonsoir vous allez bientôt vous coucher
vous êtes en pyjama
tranquille il sait qu'on a à la télé
tranquille oui c'est qu'on a la télé
c'est Cyril Hanouna on est à la télé
Louis
oui vous inquiétez pas il vous regarde
bon bah très bien alors est-ce que vous
comprenez la décision des groupes
Indochine et Louise Attaque
moi je suis pas organisateur du festival
je suis juste la ville d'accueil voilà
et on l'a appris vendredi que le que
kendo Chine ne voulait pas venir mais
c'est ses propres mains j'allais dire
une position de circonstances parce que
Perpignan depuis que je suis élu à
accueilli des dizaines d'artistes et ça
m'a posé aucun problème on a accueilli
MC Solaar on a accueilli Souchon on
accueilli 500 on a accueilli Mika on
accueilli Lanvin on en a accueilli
beaucoup comme ça et ça n'a posé aucun
problème et là tout d'un coup Indochine
pose son ultimatum je trouve ça un peu
scandale alors Monsieur Monsieur le
Maire juste le festival il devait avoir
lieu à Toulouse à la base c'est ça non
il devait avoir lieu à serrer d'accord
c'est ça une ville à côté de Perpignan
d'accord ils ont organisent les
organisateurs pour des raisons qui leur
sont propres nous ont demandé si nous
étions prêt à accueillir le festival qui
n'était pas prévu chez nous d'accord on
a dit oui parce que on avait les
capacités techniques pour le faire et
c'est pas aller au-delà moi je n'en ai
pas fait la promotion et je n'ai pas
irrigué les réseaux sociaux
de ce que Indochine a dit c'est-à-dire
qu'on utilisait leur image pour notre
promotion tout ça est faux tout ça est
faux c'est un mensonge alors il y a
Gilles Verdez qui voudrait vous dire un
mot qui est d'accord qui est d'ailleurs
comprend pas la décision d'Indochine et
Louise Attaque exactement mais alors
vous vouliez dire quoi déjà alors
Monsieur le Maire moi ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est que l'annulation
maintenant du festival à Perpignan et la
colère d'Indochine et de Louise Attaque
c'est à cause de vous et je ne comprends
pas qu'avec votre sens politique si fin
vous ayez récupéré le festival c'est ça
qui a heurté les groupes c'est que vous
avez fait sur les réseaux sociaux ou en
tout cas vous avez dit bravo on organise
etc donc on a eu l'impression les
artistes ont eu l'impression que du coup
c'était presque votre parti politique
qui organisait pour moi vous avez commis
une faute est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec moi
on me dit les déferlantes vont signer à
Perpignan je fais un tweet bienvenue au
déferlante pas bienvenue à Indochine il
n'y a que Indochine qui a réagi
maintenant ils ont tenté par en dessous
d'entraîner avec eux tous les autres
mais au départ moi je ne fais que dire
bienvenue au déferlantes je suis le
maire de la ville je suis dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales bienvenue à ce
spectacle de qualité je vois pas où est
le problème vous n'auriez pas dû faire
profil bas vous pensez bon
en fait moi je trouve que Indochine
c'est un coup de com contre-productif et
hypocrite parce que de toute façon on va
pas demander aux gens qui sont dans le
dans le festival de donner des tracts
pour défendre le programme de louyayo de
la même manière ceux qui vont aller à ce
festival on va pas leur demander mais
est-ce que vous avez voté pour le
rassemblement national ah ouais toi tu
dégages on va pas demander Indochine de
mental non plus à ceux qui achètent les
albums
plusieurs albums s'ils ont voté oui ou
non un jour dans leur vie pour le
rassemblement national donc voilà je
trouve qu'il y a une diabolisation
systématique on le sait depuis des
années
diabolisation
on fait ça à chaque fois il y a chaque
fois ils sont au second tour donc si on
doit faire ça comme ça ça ne marchera
pas je prends les gens pour des abrutis
et donc je trouve que c'est débile il
faut absolument que ce festival et lieu
pourquoi pas alors pourquoi va changer
de vie alors finalement c'est ça bah
c'est débile on prend en otage les
citoyens non le festival aujourd'hui il
est il est sans lieu d'accueil les 100
lieux d'accueil donc finalement il y a
plus lieu il y a un peu à Perpignan il
va nulle part le festival là il cherche
un lieu notre lieu qui cherche notre
lieu parce qu'il a été pris par le
chantage d'Indochine alors que jusqu'à
présent et à ma connaissance tous les
artistes prévus n'avaient pas manifesté
la même conception de la démocratie de
Madame Hidalgo avec les travaux et avec
les rats bon bah alors il y a pas de
problème
donc Indochine si on trouve un autre
lieu une autre ville à 10-15 kilomètres
Indochine vont venir mais genre Front
national de Perpignan qui vont aller
voir le concert complètement débile de
dire que la partie comme les autres
c'est ça qui est tout tendu dans leur
dans leur action
il est au deuxième
tourner
15 ou 15 ans
parce qu'il va aller se coucher
à Perpignan du coup la région Occitanie
a dit bah on coupe nos subventions
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
a torpillé de toute part le festival qui
devait se tenir à Perpignan
ah il est évident que vous aviez le
premier vice-président du département
communiste qui a incité des artistes à
ne pas venir et vous avez la région qui
a dit on va baisser la subvention je
rappelle que Madame Delga a été condamné
pour discrimination politique à l'égard
de la ville de Beaucaire et que je
regarde dans les 14 ans comment ça se
passe maintenant pour savoir s'il est
pas en tenter une action contre madame
Delga pour discrimination de la ville de
Perpignan de la même manière merci en
tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et bon dodo
[Rires]
tiens
77% non
vous êtes toujours accompagné